I believe. Permanently.
All right. I think we can say who.
My talk this morning is called, though, Robert W. Floyd In Memoriam.
And it gets kind of a different talk tonight than I've ever given before.
And I had a lot of fun putting it together. In fact, it's probably one of the easiest talks I'll ever have to give in my life because.
Well, as far as the reform is concerned,
I think maybe a lot of you are interested not only in what's going to happen next in the next few years in computer science, but.
But how did we get. How do we get to where we are today, especially? How come?
How come Stanford is such a great place for computer science at the moment.
And I think it is clear that that's the that the roots go back basically 40
years and is because of people like like Bob Floyd who who died last September,
that that this place is so great. Hi.
See Bob tagine in the audience, too.
And Jim King and Gary Hayes and other students of how in my own in my own life, I would have to say that Bob was was without a doubt,
one of the very strongest influences on my whole career and probably more than any other person.
And so that's why it is such an easy time for me to make this stuff.
What what I'm gonna do is I'm going to base my talk today on UN documents.
So not my not my reminiscences of what I think I remember from actual, you know,
actual love of things that I found in my files that were written at the time that these things happen.
And. And I hope. Yeah. And and I.
So so I had a lot of fun. Going through scraps of information.
And I'd like to show you some of these things. I hope. I hope you enjoy it, too.
Now I'm the first. So. So let me see if we can get the gist on the screen here.
This is the first report that I can see with the first report that that I found in my files was actually came from nineteen sixty,
which was before before I ever knew Bob.
In fact, this was 1960. I got my my bachelors degree in June and he was at Army Research Foundation in Chicago.
And I, I. And this.
Called it's not really called Arnst Studies, a computer program, it's really called Advanced Studies, a computer programing.
But the copy I have is very bad, is very poorly reproduced. But the eye you see better.
But this was just a description and user manual for the Moby Dick program debugging system.
Moby Dick was a was a computer used by the by the Army.
And I don't know. I don't know very much about it. But but but according to page 73 of this report, the contract personnel.
There was are blank. That's RW Floyd and Bruce.
And I forget. See the one who I will be, I don't know anyway.
And it said that they programed the interpretation and debugging language and identities.
W Floyd designed the logical syntax. And it's signed by my side.
Schwartz Anyway. Now I learned later that Bob and I learn computer programing exactly on the same machine.
It was an IBM six fifty. Bob started a year earlier night and he, he, he, he started programing the 650 in 1956.
I didn't see such a machine until the summer of 57.
But anyway, I did. This might have influenced the reason why why we got along later.
But just to set the scene, I show you.
Here's here's one of the pick one when one of the pages at the end of this year, the end of this report is 1728.
This is and here's assembly code. And I don't know if I think program programs on this.
I don't know if this is Bob Bob's work at I'm a researcher or not, but it shows the idea.
You know, you write in the machine instruction and then you say,
get on and then you get a little bit of a haiku or you try to find a way to give it a meaningful comment in in 20 characters or less on each line.
My name is it's over. My name of the 17 inst type.
Yeah. OK. And then and and then.
Then in order to satisfy your sponsors in those days,
you also present flow chart which shows how you know which which you're supposed to explain what those lines of code did not.
Anyway, this said this, this just you know, the IBM six fifty was a lot smaller and slower than the Moby Dick, but not not that much.
It was eight K of of memory and the. And it was a 10 a ten kilohertz computer.
And so seven cycle times for four for an ad if everything was positioned right.
But if but if it wasn't. You lost 98 cycle times.
Because the drum had to get around to ensure that those were the machines we started with.
Now then my my first introduction to Bob was through his his first major publication in ACMD Journal, 1961.
Here, here again, you see that it's credited to a research foundation and and it was called a descriptive language for symbol manipulation.
And this is where this became known as as Floyd Productions later on.
And actually, I think had a lot to do with with expert systems and things like that in future years.
He. But in this in this article, he explains it by a new notation of what people who are writing compilers had had been had been trying to,
you know, puzzle a puzzle over for for many years.
The people who had written about whether there were about 30 different 30, 40 different compilers written around the world.
By that time, but nobody understood really. It was kind of a miracle that the computer compiler would work around that.
And so he had these productions which are which say, yes, if you have something of this form where this delta is your cursor,
then you then you you replace it by this and you do some generation roll and.
And here's here's the I found out that I, I, I was a grad student at Caltech and I was asked to review this paper for computing reviews.
And I found the I found the perfect copy of my of my review.
I, I couldn't find that particular issue of computing reviews seems to be missing from my collection.
So I did it. So I started this paper is a significant step forward in the field of automatic programing over the past few years.
Simple averages for analyzing arithmetic expressions have been discovered independently by many people.
A condensed. Methods for explaining such algorithms obscure the essential facts.
Claire has developed a new notation which lets the trees we distinguish from the forest admirably,
points out what is really going on in translation process. Algebraic compiler.
Can you describe very precise in compactly in this notation, one can design such a compiler influence form in a few hours.
Formerly they were defined in the form of flowcharts or annotated assembly listenings which which you.
So you see that even though Bouser armor research writing is annotated as things and flowcharts, which I didn't even know when I wrote this review.
His his, his article in ACMD Journal is worth a was a nice antidote to that.
Then other notations appeared, such as tearless at Carnegie Tech Transition Diagrams,
a case tech complete assembly language of Brooklyn Morris, a Manchester University.
Now close notations at once, more compact,
more readable reviewer believes it will benefit automatic programing just as switch from text dot to dxp t has benefited work in the calculus.
And so then I go on to explain the words productions are now, then I'm in.
So as I said, I hadn't met but at the time. But I, but I did start to appreciate his work.
And in it it happened that I in the summer of 1962, I was I was finishing up a compiler.
Was it sixty two or sixty. Sixty three. And then I finished my my compiler.
I guess I think it must have been 63 anyway, right? Yeah. I spent the summer writing, writing a Fortran compiler and finished.
It was an intensive, intensive project for a year.
For three months, actually, I am not sure who is 62 or 63 anyway.
We could we could do it. By the way, there was an ACM national meeting in Syracuse in the fall and I and Bob was was a presenter there at the end.
And so I, I met him in and we talked for a long time and and the eyes are sort of a little more about.
About the things we discussed. But we found that we had lots of interests in common.
And so we so often it was it was that at that time that I started that I really could could put a face
to the person whose papers I was reading are the first letter that I have in my files from him is dated,
however, October 63. That's why I'm not sure if it's 62 or 63 when I when we met.
And I had evidently written to him about something called TTL, which I'm not sure what they are.
Some some some kind of languages. Something something.
Some kind of. Anyway, it was some it had to was something like some context, context for languages.
But another another formalism that has died out.
Then I had asked him what we were interested in.
Ambiguity because as I ever was a grad student in at at Caltech.
My first idea for for a research project was that was to look at the problem of context, three languages and find out what grammar isms can see,
whether the whether they were ambiguous or not, whether or not you could pass a string in two different ways.
And I didn't know that the problem had already been proved unsolvable.
But but I I asked Bob about the special case of the problem, which was which was whether in modern terms,
we would say whether a finite state language could be equipped with a simple,
finite state, language could be decided, whether it's ambiguous or not in particular.
I just said, what if we had a set of strings? And then we and then we just allow any number of copies of those strings like gods.
So it's C, C, I'd be A, B and A. And then you you say, you know, make any word that says you can't buy by repeating of one of these four.
And another one of the four and so on is there is a unique word decompose that into the into the, into the ones who started it.
And I didn't know the answer to this problem like I had mentioned it to Bob.
And he he replied with that with an algorithm for explaining how to how to solve that particular case of the ambiguity problem.
Well, we just found out soon afterwards that this was a well-known algorithm do to Sardina and Patterson
in 1952 that but it just shows the kind of things that we were talking about in those days.
Here's here's a letter that I got from him. The next. In February of 64.
And I had I think that he read it the day after I had visited him at his house in Topsfield, Massachusetts.
By that time, he was he was working for Computer Associates, Inc. I actually also in the previous letter.
And he. And then I remember, you know,
we we talked a lot about a lot of technical problems that I had just learned
about the sorting method that became known as Heap's Sort and weekend off.
But I also I also shared in my time related to sorting networks and and I and I had done I had
noticed a curious thing that that if you if you start out with numbers and reverse sort of seven,
six, five, four, three, two, one, and you alternately slop, you know,
the things that are that are even positions that then you start over here, then you go this way, this way, this way, this way, this way.
And you keep on swapping them. And minus one times you get you get the things in perfect, perfect order and.
And so, so bad. Then set about that sorting system.
You shall I find any sorting procedure by interchanges of adjacent lines to correctly
store all inputs if it will correctly sought an input that is in in decreasing order.
So he he vastly generalize what I had told him. And he also gave on the next stage he gave this.
This lemon, which which was a stronger result that he could prove.
Now this. I can show you from volume three of the art of computer programing that this has now survived.
And on page 240 of R.W. Floyd, 1964.
So it's a network that involves only adjacent compared comparisons of one number and the one after it is.
It is called primitive. And so Floyd proves that if this was his llama from his from from the letter I showed you.
And then. And then. Then. Then you get the theorem. The primitive network is a spreading network.
If and only if it source the single vector of numbers in reverse order.
So in other words, if you assert that one, permutation it, assert every permutation provided it has these properties to do this.
It's a beautiful result. And he and, you know, he said. And he said, was this the theorem you wanted me to find?
Ask me another set, Sara.
Yeah. Well, it wasn't a theory, you know. So it was very boring.
Now, now sixty four. I have let a whole bunch of other mail from him in 1964.
And. And and at first he he said so.
So in February when that when I started 17, he got interested in this idea of setting networks and.
And there was a there was a paper in the ACM Journal by. By Burroughs and Nelson.
I see both as a distinguished statistician and at North Carolina.
But had.
But he also doesn't happen to have been teachers of mine as undergraduates a case because both spend a year a case with me during my senior year.
And they had that they had found something that works that get that out of there were pretty good.
And they conjectured that they were optimum. And and so they presented something that would sort in elements.
Bye bye. So what we call oblivious manner, which which means you have you have a little a little module that says compare these two.
And put the maximum on this on this line and the minimum on this line.
And and and you try to find a sort of a setting network that has the smallest number of modules.
And there's a Nelson had had had had the best of the best known construction.
However, on slide that had found by the end of February of that as a way to improve their network for precisely 21 elements.
And he had reduced the number of modules from one hundred and eighteen to a hundred seventeen.
So this proved that that the beauts Nelson method wasn't optimum.
But the question was, you know, can you do better? And he is sending a copy of that to me and then also took to both.
Now he writes to Burzan, Intermarket isn't. Now he can do nine out nine items in twenty five instead of twenty seven.
So here was it here. Here was a big improvement really, relatively speaking, because here you're doing only nine.
Well now it's been proved. But since then, by the way, that both Nelson method is optimum for everything up to date at least.
And and the best of network for nine elements is still unknown.
But 20, you know, nobody's been able to beat this. Twenty five. But that.
Maybe computers are getting fast enough that we could actually prove that.
Construction is that's what it does. It's a massive computation to try all sorting network.
But, um. But here you have any any proof. And here's here's Bob.
So construction for nine elements, which which he. Which you presented with a certain notation, which then he explains how how this leads to approve.
And so then I wrote to him a few days later saying, Dear Bob, I was quite impressed indeed, awestruck,
etc. by the example you sent me last week showing improvement of two steps in the fixed comparatives fixed comparison site for nine elements.
The first example, an improvement from one 18 to 117 was interesting, but certainly not nearly as remarkable as this.
Therefore, I lost another day from book writing as I pondered this question. Bill mentioned.
Yeah. Yeah. Bill, Bill mentioned that he's still waiting for the address. The other lines of the seven.
Well, you know, in 1964, I was thinking, you know, I was trying to finish all seven fires before my son was born.
And he was born in sixty five. I mean. So and so.
And I still sort of feel this way that I'm about, you know, I'm getting closer.
So I say. So anyway, there are a few results obtained today.
I hope you check them practice. We also hope you're inspired to find bigger and better improvements.
And so then I talked about things. I had some diagrams of my own I went to.
And here I. I went up to. Starting 16 elements.
And I used a four by four.
Where he had used a three by three. He's like a generalized is not a little bit.
And then. And I was able to get that two to get to save over the both Nelson method from sixty five to sixty four of which was son.
You might not say it's very exciting, except that the both Nelson, as it was at his best war powers to the.
That's not the sort of. You know is maximum efficiency. Wasn't the case where, where you had that or even so 16 went.
It was based on foreign formulas. Those all looked like they were if it was gonna be item for any method, it would be for the powers as a two.
And it wasn't for so. So anyway, here it went. So the battery pack is very pretty.
Now generalize to three dimensional diagrams. Okay. And so. And so then he.
So. So now this this began a long correspondence on on the trading networks that that lasted over or over quite a few years.
I think there were three or four dozen letters all the time.
And every time I would get a letter from Bob, I would have to take another day away from book writing,
as you say, because because I mean, it was kind of a one upmanship.
You know, each one of us, I might affect the same when you got a letter from me.
But then. Not now. Oh, not now. Dan's I again.
You know, so he's got it. There we get this.
This gave me an insight into really looking at a scientific correspondence of other.
You know, that that you can find in the library where, you know, Linus was writing to be newly or or Euler to Goldbach or,
you know, goes to Schumacher and and and Jacoby and things like that.
Is that right now? I'm not saying that that that Bob and I are in the league with these with these great mathematicians, but that still with that,
but that it was the same kind of a flavor that must have must have been true in those first
centuries when people were exchanging their scientific or mathematical discoveries back and forth.
And so really, we we we can't quite express how hard, you know,
this enthusiasm that we know that we had for was caused by this at least these challenging problems back and forth.
And finding beautiful pattern. The way you wrote these things,
did you write drafts of these letters first and then the mock word that the secretary typed out seemed so different than the way we work today.
Yeah. Right. There's no secretary's name here. I don't know how Bob works, but in my case, my my letters.
This is obviously something I wrote myself on my own typewriter.
I recognize this is a different you know, I had a I had a typewriter at my home that I that I that I know.
I bought to select an IBM Selectric typewriter for five hundred dollars.
The people in IBM Los Angeles office said I was the only person I knew who who bought it for use in his in his own home.
But he knew I had had a kind of good touch.
But I but I certainly wrote this stuff on my own typewriter that I cut.
And I recognize the other ones. I know.
You can see the secretaries are initials at the bottom, but the Kaltech was not known for the quality of its secretaries.
I must say that's one of the reasons I came to Stanford later in high school brass.
But yeah, so so like the thing that I showed you from my computing reduce, that was obviously a draft that I did.
And I put cotton paper in my in my machine.
And I you know, when when I wrote in the symbols afterwards, I didn't get perfect alignment with the carbon paper, with the with the original.
But these were this was the way we the way we get the end and you'll see other other letters written in longhand coming up.
OK. So anyway, eventually a lot of Bob's letters had had they.
Sure. They hear a lot of thought of of a power in calculus and and quantitative math.
Mathematics said that you don't see in his publications. But he knows this was part of his.
You think now. Now this is the next thing I want to show you is is one of the greatest papers I think
ever written in the computer and certainly in the in the in the Empire I in the 60s.
You have to remember that the computer science had three. It was sort of divided into divided into three parts and the Internet.
And there was almost nothing else really. It as far as the what was done in the C.S. Department, you had you had numerical analysis.
You had artificial. Diligence and you had programing languages, and these were this was sort of it was called up into into these three areas and.
And this was the masterpiece of the programing languages area.
But Bob surveyed the field and and in this paper, I mean, he he hit he added.
It wasn't just a survey, but he but he put the whole thing into order and provided a brand new idea, which which I want to show you quickly here.
And here he talks about it, a new way to to to proceed.
The passing of algebraic language.
And he says he says this analyzer makes use of a complicated hierarchy of subordinate goals in seeking his principal goal.
We introduce it with a metaphor. Suppose a man is assigned the goal of analyzing a sentence in a phrase structure, language of known grammar.
Now, this was the 60s, you remember? Now we would say a person. But anyway, he has the power to hire subordinates, assign them tasks and fire them.
If they fail, they in turn have the same power.
Every man will be told only once tried to find a G where G is a symbol of the language may thereafter be repeatedly told.
Try again. If the particular instance of a G. That he finds proves unsatisfactory to his superiors.
And now it turned out that this is a brand new control structure which now we could call recursive Cortines or thread's.
Anyway, I think this is this is this is in some senses, the birth of object oriented programing.
The idea that these these people retain their.
And serve that the person is hired. But then he then he gives up.
He gives a report to his superior. But the superior says try again.
And at this point, the man retains all of the stack and everything that he knew that that had gotten him to this point.
And it's a it's a. It was it was an unknown control structure in it in programing at the time.
And it was why Bob was able in this, you know, not only in the survey,
but to present a brand new method that that that didn't have bugs in it for the first time.
Because other people's methods are using Orlean's structures would break down a complicated example.
And that. Now, here's a handwritten letter that I wrote to Bob as of from a 10 page letter written at the end of 64.
And I had just at that time been finishing my chapter on CHOP, the first draft of my Chapter 10,
which was on on how to how to pass, how to how do you know how to write process for compilers.
And then. And I had done in the previous pages of this letter, I had I had sketched out what later became known as L.R. of key passing algorithm.
And in here I said I must apologize for the complexity of my construction.
Indeed it is. Are too complicated to put in my book.
I was there now. Now, of course, when I finally do get around to having Chapter 10, I.
I have to start with l'arc pricing, because that that that that that became an industry in itself in YAC and all these other things based on it.
But at this time, it was so complicated. I didn't you know, I figured it was way beyond the scope of the book.
Anyway, I think this seems to be inherent in this problem.
I know of at least three PTSD theses that were entirely concerned with only the most simple cases of parts of this problem.
And then it's Denis's as I go further into Chapter 10.
I've become more convinced that only five really worthwhile papers on scanning techniques have ever been written.
And you were the author of all five of them. OK. And up.
And I think anyone who studies the early literature programing language will come to that same conclusion.
And then I say, however, I wish you hadn't come up with the proof, unquote, that Elga, 60, can't be defined in an in depth.
It's not a all you proved was that certain semantic restriction couldn't be specified.
Anyway, we got into some debates also at this time. Now, the next the next day, I want to show you a major paper that that came out in 67.
But it was really imbibes thinking all this all the way through here, not assigning meanings to programs.
And this is really the you know, about and I talked about a huge number of interesting algorithms over the years.
But the thing that I really learned most from Bob was and then what really changed my life was,
was that he was the first person who who showed me who connected the mathematical and the
programing parts of my life and show me that programs could actually be proved correct,
not just understood. And that was the prevailing wisdom.
And for, you know, up until up until the 60s,
almost 100 percent of all people writing computer program would never think of of of that as having anything to do with with with with
if the program you would you would you would the hack where you would write it and you would total you must either to find a value,
you'd remove the body and patch it. And so it worked until it, until you couldn't make it fail.
And then you come to finally say, yeah, I think I understand all that.
The people like that. There were some of the early completers told me that they lived in dread,
that the next day somebody would come up with a statement that wouldn't wouldn't pass correctly.
That's right. But but all the way through and in programing, we had one we never thought.
I mean, the question of how do you know which is right? Was I didn't even enter our heads.
It was not there. It was it was just not a concept that I never had.
Not you know, I I was I was a programmer and, you know, did consoling for birds and things like this.
But but then I will also go on to be a mathematician and math in mathematics recruiting.
And but that's what bothers the person who showed me that really I could prove things about programs as well.
A complete revelation that that that that that that this could be done.
And and one of the pioneering papers then was this.
What about what's now called a void assertions or something like this, the say signing meanings to programs.
And what he showed is that basically you could you could if you if you had a program represented,
say, by a flowchart, you could decorate it by assertions that are true.
At this part of the program and you can show that if this is true before the step, then then then this is true afterwards.
And you can still prove by induction that that you get the right answer because because
every step of the program preserves of the things that are true before and after that step.
And this became, of course, another another big industry and many, many, many great advances over the years on this.
But that. And and I I think of Jim King's thesis was related to this work right now.
And that can be and that was done at Carnegie where where Bob was at that time.
You see at the bottom of this. This this reprint here.
Now, I want to show you one other letter from that time is that I wrote in 67.
This I wrote to Killington, executive editor of the ACM Journal and Communication.
She was in charge of getting the all the papers into it, into print.
And she was really I had great respect for her and.
And I wrote a long tribute to her when when she retired many years later,
she had she was faced with with a completely new technical field and house and how to and how to establish good typographic conventions.
She she was largely responsible for it, for the way, for example,
ALGOL 60 programs got types that would boldface in certain ways and and things like this.
And a structure that came out. It was it was it was it was a sheep.
They had to wrestle with this problem because computer science had new new problems of formatting that that other fifield's hadn't faced before now.
But here I take care. I was editor of the ASTM, my journal section.
I forget which section. It was probably programing language section in 67.
And I said, Do you send me three letters in May while I was abroad, all dealing essentially with cutting publication costs.
I was unhappy to read of your decision to make Floyd submit Leray letter flowcharts for his article,
especially since I had no chance to communicate my feelings to you.
I was in Europe for three weeks.
You said you could not authorize the printer's art department to prepare figures other than are under exceptional circumstances.
Well, I feel this case presents Exceptional Circumstances.
One Loyce article, perhaps more than any other article I've ever seen, is based almost entirely on illustrations coordinated with text.
To such an extent,
the effectiveness of the article will be considerably degraded if typeset text is not used in the diagrams to match the printing in the main text,
saying that he should prepare his own diagrams.
As in this case, like telling our authors never to use mathematical formulas unless they submit handled a copy for them to Professor First,
and one of our best and most faithful referees and ACM publications for many
years has volunteered much of his valuable time to this often thankless job.
How he is now. He is an associate editor of JCA and we certainly owe him a decent treatment of his article and served then.
Since your letter of May 10th gave me, it gave him a deadline of May 25th,
I presume he has already been obliged to have the new flowcharts made up here.
Here I'm writing in June. I believe we should at least paste types that copy into the drawings he has supplied.
By the way, I was careful to mark the mask of I sent you all the copy to be italicize with blue underlined.
Flag does not have access to this information,
which in several cases involves some situations where a task rolling were mixed in a way we could not anticipate.
When he said sent the drawings to you, he could not. So I hope you can adhere to the way I marked it up on your unique copy.
So anyway, I'm telling. I'm giving her all this. I'm quite surprised that you feel you must be so stingy at a time when several
publishing houses are starting up new journals which have no page charges,
presumably as a profit making venture.
The Journal of Combinatorial Theory Academic Press recently made up six illustrations for me in a short article I submitted to them.
How can ACMD be going broke, especially now that Doose have gone up 40 percent?
I'm I'm certainly all for cutting costs, but not as a great sacrifice in quality.
By the way, academic Chris is recently brought up by Elsevier, and I'm now fighting the battle on the other side.
But that's another another thing now. By the way, here, here's.
You know, I had to work and work on typography.
I later on in my career, as some of you know, antiracist turning to another topic, I agree with you as a typewriter style type used in June 66.
Communications was rather ugly, but mostly because it was too big. The publishers of my book have found a very nice typewriter front.
It looks fine even when mixed with Rowin and Italic, as you once told me, was impossible.
So I think I was correct in raising the matter with you 18 months ago and so on.
Anyway, we were talking about typographic issues already in 1967,
but I'm glad to see that Bob's article, which was a very another famous article in ASTM journal.
This was called Non-Deterministic Algorithm's, where he represented a paradigm that's now been used.
Many, many are actually programing languages have been based on on on this.
You can look at the diagrams they know and and they and the ACM did pasted not, you know, type of fairly close to the matches if things.
So at least that was that would that would that they did follow follow through on.
Now Bob was asked to be by Alison Lisick to be the reader for the art of computer programing, you know, before,
before publication and the finished chapter, one of this stuff which turned out to be the first half of volume one.
I finished Chapter one in in the summer of 1965 when my son was born.
And and I at least finish Chapter one and they send it off to Bob for his for his review and his.
And so here's his comments he made to the to the first draft of it that were that were done in the summaries as well.
I liked the chapter, but I think it couldn't be improved by chopping most of the humor and anecdotes.
Now, you know. Well, I don't know. I think I. I probably chopped.
A little bit of it, but I anyway retain the historical material, and in he sense,
the sections I particularly liked include as such and such a least interested in one, two, six and one two eight.
This is binomial coefficients and Fibonacci numbers, actually.
So anyway, he said the system of rating problems underestimates the difficulty for, say, car seniors.
And it designates too many with the with the arrow that recommends a particular exercise.
Are the author's personal notes of the vice are often variable at times. So the non-technical matter gets mature, gets a little thick.
And so then he goes. He goes and gives it gives it a detailed critique for, like some of, you know, the beginning of time.
One has a flowchart saying how to read the series of books. He says, I don't like this flowchart, nor the humor.
Generally, the book is sufficiently advanced that sugar coating should not be required.
And this takes up three pages of space.
He he gave very detailed comments, you know, on on things gave gave better answers, solutions to some of the exercises.
And, you know, so. So, again, you can see how helpful he was to me at this critical stage in my my life.
Here is a letter that I wrote. Actually, it doesn't show up here as if it was 19 February nineteen sixty seven.
Bob, I have a feeling this is going to be a somewhat extraordinary letter.
During the last year or so, I've been getting lots of offers of employment from other colleges.
You see them at Caltech? I think I told you that I plan in their plan for a long time to decide on the
permanent home where I will want to live the rest of my life and to move there
after the year I spent in Princeton working for the government to move in
September sixty nine due to the present supply and demand in computer science.
I'm fortunate enough to be able to pick just about any place I want to go.
But there are several good places and it's quite a dilemma to decide what I should do.
I believe the four places that are now uppermost in my mind are Stanford, Cornell, Harvard and Caltech in that order.
I expect to take about a year before I make up my mind with Jill's help occurs to me
that I would very much like to be located the same place you are if this is feasible.
At any rate, your plans have gone to your place in the non-linear function.
I am trying to optimize. I know you don't like Southern California and I don't like Pittsburgh.
So if we are going to ever going to get together, it seems Cornell or Stanford are the most likely places.
I spoke to Heart Mannus and foresighted about the possibility of making an offer for
you at the same time as to me and both seem to think this was an excellent idea. So anyway, I would like to support it.
So I wrote this letter and Bob Bob's reply comes that longhand, which means that maybe they weren't being typed by secretary.
What about your last letter and off the record? So maybe I should read it.
I tend to agree with your decisions. My attitude about the university is in question.
Is this okay? So then he goes on Razali, all the people you know, I mean, should I read this?
Harvard, Harvard, rather we can computer science now with Salt and Wang and Fisher gone, very limited opportunity promotion to tenure,
which is why they lost Fisher, a great university but not promising for any new and growing discipline.
M.I.T. will be very good if they give computer science a home of its own.
As in so many courses.
And then not Stanford, one of the best faculties in computing, a great, very great university and a beautiful part of the country.
The only problem is that they are overloaded now.
They have one hundred and twenty students while Carnegie is this is going from 35 to perhaps 50 this year.
From what Pernice tells me, it might be best to let this get worked out before going there, though they may be able to do so quickly.
I understand that lack of space is also a problem. Some students are quoted several miles from the department the next page.
We don't plan to spend the rest of our lives in Pittsburgh, so it's not a bad city right now.
Stanford looks like the best choice in the Bay Area would be a great place to live.
I'd say you want to make the move. I don't have any plans that would conflict.
And I will be very tempted to go to separate myself. I probably will go, in fact.
So that was what Bob wrote to me in February of sixty seven.
I found also the letter of recommendation that I wrote for his application to Stanford.
I'm pleased to be able to write a letter for Robert W. Ford.
I don't know anyone I could recommend more highly used the most gifted man in his age bracket that I've ever met.
Some of his published papers have been significant moral force in the development of computer science,
notably his introduction of precedent's grammars, which I didn't mentioned so far, Priess thought algorithm methods of assigning meanings to programs.
I've also had the pleasure of clearing on frequent correspondence with him for five years.
I'm quite familiar with this unpublished work to this correspondence covers a wide variety of topics.
For example, graph theory with problems in some groups, mathematical notations, algorithms for syntactic analysis,
theorems about languages, algorithms for manipulating data structures, optimum sorting schemes, etc., etc.
While I was editing the ACM Communications, the Journal, I asked him to serve as referee for several papers.
It was not uncommon for him to. Four or five page review containing important suggestions for improvement is a good record.
Working with students at Carnegie and both undergraduate and graduate level.
By the way, not only was Jim King has his peers there, but also Zohar Mannah and Jay Early.
At least he is one of the rare people who have considerable experience and expertize both
in writing computer programs and in developing useful theories related to programing.
This is great. This is a key thing. You had people who were here irritations but never was set foot in a computer room and and vice versa.
Never, never, never, never. In theory, I think it was the first person to suggest that computer programs should be proved correct,
not just free, but to develop means of making such proofs. This was the real contribution of this paper on Precedent's Grammar.
It was the birth of the theory of practical syntax analysis.
Since by 9:00 this time, the idea of proving the correctness of programs had been almost entirely forgotten, Floyd had been extremely influential.
Reestablishing this principle as a true computer science with Capital C and a capital
s special tallies seemed to be a the ability to devise ingenious algorithms,
amateur constructions, b, those who developed non-trivial new theories that are both practical and mathematical interest.
C ability to organize a large body of loosely connected material to perceive the most important ideas.
D A talent for good exposition, for finding just the right words.
To express an idea whose only fault known to me is that he is sometimes a little too sensitive, too much the perfectionist.
For example, although he has lived in the East nearly all his life,
he has already decided that no California wine is worth thinking except except he goes away.
One further remark is perhaps necessary, considering contemporary standards of society, unquote.
Clearly has never gone through the formalities of obtaining a PFG degree.
I believe this was due primarily the fact that he entered graduate school at the University of Chicago
when he was only 16 or 17 years old as part of an experimental accelerated education program.
This was not a mature enough age to do graduate work.
Certainly he has written at least a dozen papers by now, each of which is superior to any PSAT thesis I have ever seen in computer science.
The mere fact that he has never formally received the degrees should be quite irrelevant.
But Bob used to tell me that he was he was gonna get a PSP by the green stamp method.
He had understood that if he could collect a, you know, one hundred letters from people addressing him as Dr. Floyd,
that there was there was some university in Arizona that would give him a degree. I found that.
I found that I want to find pictures of him from the 60s when I when most of this took place.
But I wasn't successful.
But I think outside, actually, on the first floor, there's a picture that goes back earlier than me, but this one comes from 1972.
And Bob and I and actually, if you if if you know, you can't really zoom up any closer on it.
But if you could really look at this at this close,
you would you would see that that this photo was what was done on a on an ink printer using the lens Steinberg method of making half tones.
I wish I wish it was you know, it is quite appropriate.
So about this time and about this time, 1972 is when Bob came up with his with his method for making have some pictures on a lot of other pixels.
And and it's it's, of course, now not uncommon use as a software.
And for Bob's former students who are here in the audience, I have extra copies of this picture to get to give.
Now I'm continuing on.
How am I doing on time? OK. So here's a letter that I wrote to the American Academy of Arts and Sciences in 1974.
This the American Academy. You know, our next follows are leading people in in both the humanities and sciences.
And. And they had asked for comments on the members in opening when considering computer scientists.
It's difficult to rank them with respect to mathematicians, physicists, etc. since computer science is so young,
a mathematician like Lame or Poya has been producing high quality work consistently for 50 years or more.
And this is much more than a computer scientists could possibly do.
This makes it easier for computer scientists like myself, and perhaps it's too easy to become a fellow.
I think I had just been elected as a fellow of this organization anyway.
On the other hand, there are outstanding mathematicians like Bellmon and Thompson, whose work spans only 20 years or so.
That is closer to what a leading computer scientists say 50 years would have, to his credit.
I will list the two candidates who are generally recognized as leading pioneers and whose names are household words,
whose contributions span a broad range of topics as well as a long span of time.
Persistent quality as good Dykstra,
who is responsible for more landmark contributions in non theoretical aspects of computer science than any other man,
namely the current revolution in programing methodology, fundamental principles of synchronizing cooperating processes,
methods for implementing recursive processes as well as important algorithms.
Such aspects of computer science are the hardest in which to make fundamental breakthroughs.
He is also able to irritation, obviously, is the second person who is responsible for many of the leading theoretical ideas of computer science,
as well as chairman of what I think is leading academic department mine.
But I'm trying to be unbiased.
His work is decided more than twice as much as any other persons in the series of books I am writing summarizing what is known about programing.
This fundamental contribution to the syntaxes smacks of programing languages.
The study of computational complexity and the proof of program correctness has been a great influence for many years,
and he has also invented dozens of important techniques that are now in common use.
So, you see, this was a few years later. Now using different terms to describe why Bob is is is a world leader,
but it's clear that these things are are really, you know, sounding large areas of our field.
I. I wrote to the Guggenheim Foundation the following summer.
I don't know if I've got a Guggenheim or not, but he put it to sea. He was chair of our department for three years.
And. And then now he's entitled to two years of sabbatical, which you took out of my teeth.
And so. So I imagine he he was supported by Guggenheim at least one point.
Anyway, here I'm saying Tresser Floyd is one of the most outstanding computer scientists in the world.
My mind is one of the top three during his career, and he has been a leading light in the development of many of the key concepts of our discipline.
And here I say a production language to describe algebraic passing techniques,
not conflate production notion of precedent's grammar, semantics of programing languages,
automatic techniques for constructing computer programs and proving they're correct in each of these
contributions had essentially created an important subfield research later pursued by hundreds of people.
Besides this, he has invented many algorithms.
The practical importance, for example, to find our shortest paths in the network to sort numbers into order to find the median of a set of data.
Several landmark theoretical papers that show certain problems are intrinsically hard.
Examples of this I can cite his recent discovery of the fastest possible way to add numbers.
This result meant that he had to invent, in addition, procedure faster than any others here to for known.
And to prove that North faster method will ever be possible.
Also, these were non-trivial innovations in my recent book that reviews what is known about sorting and searching.
His work is cited 20 times, far more than any other person.
In fact, I can I can sort of show you that from the index here, the volume three.
Yeah. You see here. So you see that now?
Now. Actually, it's not. This is this is mathematics, not not computer science.
But Floyd is is way and also, you know, half a dozen times in the in each advance wanted to do so.
So this this is his published papers showing amazing bread,
especially when one realizes so many of them have been pioneering venture ventures that became milestones.
I'm sure that wherever he proposes to do during a sabbatical year will be a great future value to science.
I highly recommend support by the Guggenheim Foundation.
Now, as during the time Bob was was chair of our department,
one of the big issues that he had to face besides the normal things about a going department was that that we had
that had a chance to have a new building and and to bring the department together under one roof for the first time.
And it became a Margaret. Jack saw a lot of you remember.
That was right at the center of campus, not in the city center of the quad.
And. And here's here's a memo that I wrote in December of seventy five when we were still looking at all kind of blueprints and so on.
And I just said, thanks for all the fireworks you've ever done together with the architects for the new building, this will have a lasting payoff.
We all owe you a huge debt of gratitude. In fact, that took the ascetics extremely,
extremely carefully and worked with all of the and worked in detail with the architects of that spent incredible amount of time on his letters.
I wrote to him at M.I.T. in 78, November 78.
The faculty had his first chance to walk through Margaret Jex Hall yesterday. Building has taken shape nicely.
The roof is finished to the winter rains, if we get any, won't be a problem for the workmen.
Doing the finishing carpentry work is super quality in the spaces are nice to walk through and being
so I'm writing to say thanks for all the energy you contributed towards the success of the project.
Thanks from all of us. And now, as it says, P.S., I'm enjoying the telephone poker game that Rebecca told me about.
This is another topic anyway. We are so, so bad, you know, as contributed not only to the to the to the pure scientific things,
but also as a as a you know, as a public servant, an administrator and doing and doing nitty gritty things.
Here's a picture that that's in the Stanford news service have had from from 1976,
which was a period when he was when he was chair, I, I, I tried to find it on this.
I had a had Internet address, but it's not online anymore.
But it was but I got this from somebody and it's another good picture to show.
It gives the feeling of both of those days.
Here's a letter I wrote at the end of his chairmanship.
Thank you to the end for the outstanding services you gave our department as chairperson these last years.
You focused on and solve the critical problems facing us in the present and future strength of our department is due in large measure to your efforts.
Effects will last for a long time. Not having the energy to be chairman myself.
I am doubly grateful that you sacrificed so much of your time for these important tasks.
Here's the I have a picture from 1979, which is when you came back from there, but unfortunately it was taken.
This is the picture from the photo board at Stanford and I.
Have you taken by a student who who is not not good at focusing the camera, but it does.
But anyway, it's an it's it's it's kind of a collective picture.
Any way of showing him in front of his office.
And Margaret Jigsaw. I mean, this was the corridor.
I think you went. I had it now.
Let's see, I neglected to mention two things from early days.
One, now vivid memory is that from 1969, the day that President Nixon invaded Cambodia, and we decided that to go on strike.
And this was this was sort of the last straw. And so we did so.
So we've set. And so Bob and I up and joined a lot of other students and I don't know,
probably a few other faculty picket picketing Pine Hall so that nobody would be able to get into the computer center in those days.
And that's us. And we of course, we knew that the only important thing was to at the statistics that would be reported as to how many people picketed.
And so we sat there talking about sorting networks to each other.
You know, we were we were saying, no, no, no business as usual.
But in fact, we were still doing computer science, as it were, sitting there picketing that some time.
How was the computing center? And so there was.
And so we would just say anybody wants to come and do their homework and computing, you know, to run.
And you had to punch card. You got to set your idea, submit your cards and playing hard to get to get your program run.
So so we just prevented anybody from going into the into paying off. And that's what the whole campus was in no way.
We said, no, no, we're not going to teach classes today. It was 1969.
Stanford was you know, you know, they they torsional seen a hall.
And it was quite an interesting place trying to be at a university.
When we would give lectures, I would draw a square root sign to show that, you know,
that I was supporting radicalism, you know, proud of, you know, saying, you know what?
Let's let's talk A of science, because, you know, it's cool. But but but let's remember that the world is having problems and stuff like that.
Another thing from the early days of Bob that inspired a private seminar which was given to throughout and entering graduate students.
And this would be every every student. The students I would would work in teams of to solve many research problems with
two weeks per problem and have extremely important part of many people education.
So many of our students have come back and said that this was the thing, that they would be the class if they learned the most from.
And Bob pioneered this class. He took her from George Forsyth, who had learned similar things from George Herbert.
That said, the bad reading was was my modeling for it.
And then he and I alternated teaching it for a while. And so that's another thing I wanted to mention.
I love getting getting toys first later years of it in the 80s.
I was working mostly on typography, although Bob and I did that, did do a joint paper, but something we call edition machines.
And I had a note in my diary thing that in nineteen eighty five we had a long talk.
It doesn't say what what about. And then afterwards we went out to see Woody Allen movie The Purple Rose of Cairo.
In nineteen eighty nine, Bob and I went up to San Francisco to see a play called Breaking the Code, which was about Alan Turing.
And I think, you know that that five won the Turing Award, which is the highest award of our of our computer science today.
And this that was in 1978. And he and so his his his his Turing lectures is in this know in this book about.
About the main lectures. And and I, I reread it yesterday and I was I was glad to know that actually one of the paradigm so that that he talked about
his Turing Lecture event involves some ideas that he said in the last time he would say he would like to have.
He says, yeah, well, most current languages, one could not present the main program procedures and data declarations in this order,
some preliminary human text shuffling of a separate ready mechanize, which is usually required further.
Any variables used in more than one must be global and something like this.
He says that the detailed breakdown of a problem into a hierarchy of procedures typically results in very inefficient code,
even though most the procedures are being called from only one place. Could it be efficiently implemented by macro expansion?
Well, I was really struck by this because it turned out that this is what is one of the main reasons I like Seawell for my programing.
Now, when I when I came up with a with literate programing I hadn't thought of.
Realize that Bob had anticipated the idea in his touring lecture. The let's see.
So they say in eighty nine. We went to see this.
The play about touring. And we and we talked to the actor afterwards mentioning our own our own connection to touring.
Bob saw when Bob retired in 1993, he had done his his book had had had come out with with with with Richard Bago.
This was really summarized many of the ideas that he had worked on in his life just to purchase a part of his life, really.
That that I wasn't personally much involved with except in the early days when we were talking about.
About connections between automata and and programing and languages.
But that I remember that that Bob had read one of the last times I spoke to him.
He was. He had just received the translation of this book into German.
And he was so extremely happy that the trance that that was not only translated, but also a very good translation,
because Bob had, you know, had been taking out of Stanford courses in advanced course, in German literature and so on.
He thought he could really appreciate the German link. I guess I also mentioned that Bob and I often would go hiking now.
We went one time to the desert. We went out once.
I remember you introduced me to Coal State Park in the East Bay.
And. And so we would often talk about science and those and those things.
All you see, I have lots and lots of memories. And here's the last thing I want to show you is.
Well, now, two, two. I'm sorry. I got one letter I wanted to find, but I couldn't find in my files.
But I but I know I had it. I know I had it. Fifteen years ago.
So somewhere here I thought I had. This is it.
This is my book on mathematical writing where I write like one quarter I, I talk to students about how to write technical art, technical articles.
And I showed a letter from Butterflied letter opened by saying, Don, please stop using so many exclamation points.
Exclamation point. And then, you know, he said that he started every sentence, had more and more exclamation points, and so he was making me sick.
That's a commission for that commission going to the point, you know. And so I took a lesson from that.
And, you know, and I and I looked in the art of computer program, I found about two exclamation points per page.
And so I so I realized, you know, I completely change my my style after that point.
And I want to show you that letter today. But I am able to retrieve it somewhere in my files as it is.
But the last thing I want to show you is this.
I'm of my my my own papers are being are being collected and there is going to be eight books, God willing, when they're all done.
And four of the books have been published already. For example, the selected papers and computer science.
I dedicated it to George Forsyth, who is the founder of this department.
Now, the book, the book that plant called Selected Papers on Design of Algorithms.
I had decided sometime ago to to dedicate that to Butterfly.
And in fact, right now, at the moment, exactly one page of that book has been typeset, and it's a dedication page.
And so here I'm showing you the dedication page. Can you zoom in on this, too?
My, my my partner in. Now you have to look at the Oxford English Dictionary to find out that this is an old way of saying algorithm matlab.
But anyway, I looked at the at the date of the file.
When I looked in my computer file, you know, to find out, when I when I typed that is when I cleared the file.
And it was September 20th, 2000, almost exactly a year before Bob's death.
I, I, I certainly hope that that this and in this book, of course, will be reprinted the joint papers.
We may be able to make some remarks in the preface about my my indebtedness to Bob.
And I'm hoping in this way to to express some of the lasting appreciation I have.
Hope I could give you some of the flavor of this in my talk this morning.
Thank you. Question.
Question. Very I noticed when you showed me the index entry for Floyd, it didn't expand his middle name.
This was you. Do you do this? This is true, right? In fact, one of the letters I found is that was.
But in fact, I given this is this is actually the complete, complete name.
So the fact that there is no period after the W.
So when you have W a period that's an abbreviation for W with on the period.
And I was very fond of pointing out that young people like Harry S. Truman, it was the same thing that the middle name was was something else.
But he had it legally changed to W. A good question.
Thank you for. We have our great.